[Music]  painting this picture does not take away  from the fact that you're actually in a  relationship there's gonna be Rules of  Engagement yeah you are already in a  relationship so whatever you think  you're running away from you've already  created they're just trying to make it  sound like it's not that exactly and  that's why but that's you're lying to  yourself  listen did I not just say somebody that  is like my bestie somebody that we hang  out very well because we do have a  relationship it's not just a traditional  relationship why would you know any of  them already because I don't want to be  with somebody I don't want to have to  live the seafood in love with him well  maybe if if you're not letting yourself  fool